um it's really exciting to see so many
of you can come
uh i hope you all had a good bet at
night and enjoy the talk
get to know better about search and
confidence
so
before i get started i just want to
quickly uh give a intro about tumblr
itself
so tumblr was founded by david carr in
john 7
it's overused in huge popularity as a
population platform as a brand now we
have
more than 160 million blogs
and yeah it's a huge number and
in the post we have more than 70 billion
posts
massive content and most of them are
really really great
we also
on a social network people
who have the common interest can connect
with each other and share great content
i just took a screenshot of my dashboard
so that you can know how tumblr looks
like
by the way good question how many of you
are tumblr users
wow awesome thank you great answers
so
with such massive content uh search
become a very important way and very
effective way to find good content and
consume every day we are seeing about 50
million queries from a user
um
but as important as it is a couple of
search for a long time
it was the circuit functionality was
very limited
um from zone 7 to 2012 in fact actually
up to early 2013.
the pretty much the only search
available at tumblr was called tag page
essentially
for given
for given tag the return visit the posts
and underline it was a huge bicycle
table with a tag id to post id and
attempt stem so
when users
type a query everything converting to
one single tag id then
return the posts in the reverse
chronological order so it was very very
basic it works okay when you search just
one single tag but anything more than
that becomes almost impossible
especially when we have such massive
content
um
also
there was no easy way to find blogs we
do have a human uh
curated directory
we call spotlight so
people can kind of navigate this
directory to find blogs they might
interested but again this is just tiny
little bit about all the blogs that we
have
so
in 2012 um
the leadership team at tumblr finally
decided to have a dedicated team to take
on search and discovery because it's
become
so much more important with fast growth
of users and content
so in july 2012
jacques
who is also here um
he's the first search engineer uh john
tumbler then i followed that with
bennett beethoven
patrick adam um so together work with
the design team and the front front-end
team we were able to build a set of
exciting new search features from
granddad in 2013 including post search
blog search theme search
personalized recommendation and a bunch
of things so in the next couple of
slides i will quickly walk you through
what are the features available at
search at tumblr then i will talk about
the underlying architecture
frameworks and some of the
details about implementation
first and foremost
this whole new search main page we
launched last year was really bring our
users search experience to a totally new
level because
not only allow you to do post search
it also give you the
very decent capability to search nice
blogs
it also offers you the really terms you
can search more for the post search
there is no longer a limit on single tag
it's a full text search
it also gives you the rank results based
on
the combination of recency
popularity and also text relevancy um
and
it allows you to filter
results by post type post up is one
very unique feature at tumblr is that we
have seven predefined
post types
it has a lot of popularity among our
users so for search we also allow users
to do that
uh follow blog search uh phantom blog is
one of the top priority for tumblr
because
dashboard is
i just mentioned in the previous slides
we have this concept called dashboard
it's similar like facebook's
newsfeed and
twitter's timeline
essentially all the posts coming from
the blogs you follow appear in the
dashboard our users spend more than 50
percent time in their dashboard consume
all the
other content they are interested so
to very large extent the experience of
terminal user decided by their dashboard
and dashboard designed by
who they follow so
help us to find the great vlogs to
follow is very very important we build
this blog search not only you can search
by name or title we also find
we also look at all the posts published
by this blog
and look at the engagement of that post
for related to the query you are sending
then we decide what are the blogs really
for this particular query uh our top
blogs and we return to our users uh and
driven a lot of follows
from that
um we also have a given blog trying to
compute what are the best posts so user
can get a very quick preview of that
in addition to this new search we also
build uh autocompletes
which we feel like is not only a
convenient functionality but also it's a
great opportunity for tumblr to show our
user interactively what we have because
a big problem for us is really that user
to discover great content at tumblr we
have such massive content so when people
type we will give them this interactive
autocompletes
i think it's a great way to get people
more engaged
it's also used not only in the search
but also when people create a new post
they can do mention mention will be auto
complete and
for the tag we're trying to suggest
relevant attacks when they type
we also
search is also powering the personalized
recommendation
for
again for the same priority we want
people to follow really great blogs so
we're trying to help our user by
looking at the social graph who they
follow and then we look at
the people they follow what kind of
vlogs they like
so we come up with a better
recommendation for our user we also
utilize
users a little bit history activities to
help users to get a better blog follow
same thing we do dashboard digest which
is we're trying to get the best posts in
the dashboard in a weekly base so we
send email to users that helps our get
people more engaged
we also
in 2013 very exciting we we also in
addition to our search we did chant
discovery so
this is also another effort trying to
that our user know what are the
interesting content at tumblr and we can
push to our users so user will get more
engaged and use tumblr
more we do chatting tags and training
blogs and also you can see we create a
nice charts so that our editors and
sales team they can actually understand
what right now trending and given this
trending tag how the historical trend
looks like
last search we did was same search same
is a one very unique
elements at the tumblr so we allow users
to customize their blog and the theme is
people can create themes and they can
even
sell themes to other people so it's kind
of like
one of the commercial part of tumblr and
for a long time there's no way to search
them there was again it was a directory
you have to go different level of
directory but now we also make that
searchable
okay so
all those are kind of such features we
built in 2013. now i want to
go a little bit in the engineering side
talk about how we built this especially
within a year with a team of six uh we
are able to build a pretty big set of
features i think one key thing is we
learned uh when we look back at things
in the very beginning we uh build a two
framework which
uh kind of like generalize a lot of
uh common commonality common functions
of different service so that we can
utilize these common frameworks to apply
to different services so reduce the
development time
in this slide
it's a lot of stuff here but if you look
at
in the
left side
you can see essentially these three
layers the first layer we call the
search online layer
this is a layer
interactive with user request so when
users send the queries in
from one of our servers either is post
search service or tab ahead
the online layer will take this request
and the other services are built on on
top of this
search online framework which handle a
lot of common parts then the online
layer will deal with will
the data layer data layer contains all
the key data which
all the service is built upon for
example there will be index
for the post search and for block search
another type of data is we call a signal
that many use for ranking
all the
service they have their own ranking
formula and their own set of signals so
it's also served in this data layer
uh
another type of data in this layer is we
call a precomputed search results
because tumblr has very high
query traffic and have lots of data so
we do a lot of pre-computation
using our hadoop cluster to pre-generate
those such data so that we can really do
search fast
so the
third layer we are here is we call it
search offline
because it's pretty much independent of
user query we can do we can take a
little bit of time to
do the computation
um
for the offline the two major input data
uh one is a more real-time stream
we call the file geyser uh kind of
similar to twitter's uh stream
we also have a lot of batch data coming
from
scoop which is a
kind of a
copy of our mass secure database and we
also have a lot of scrap logs those
scrap logs are more from the user uh
activities and
so coming from our php app which
contains a lot of valuable information
so with these two data we
uh again we have a search offline
framework which uh helped to build a lot
of different jobs to
analyze and process those data to
generate all the different pieces of
data here
indices signals and precomputed search
results
um
next slides i will give a quick summary
of the like software stack what a
software we're using you know such
online layer we mainly
we're using
this
php
plus h8 proxy
ngx
and the memcache is used everywhere for
the caching purpose
then we use icing for monitoring and for
scrub to collect our logs
yes
always
uh
memcache essentially doesn't have uh a
big difference they don't have memcache
like persistence
uh for redis we not only use as a cache
but we we have um
a great
in-house software called rediscover so
essentially we use that at more like um
data distributed data serving layer uh
it's very scalable and it's very fast it
has a persistence
so that's the difference
and we use auburn tsdb to collect all
the metrics so that we can easily see
all kinds of report
in the data layer
solar is more useful
serving all those inverted index data
radis
is a great way to
have have this persistency to save to
serve the signals and pre-computed data
and mysql
is the
where we store the main documents so
automatic information about posts uh
blogs they're all storing the
masquerade search offline
we
we we have a pretty big hadoop cluster
and
we run
different jobs written in hive in pig in
scouting and pythons many for streaming
and we also have a
java program to to do to
interact with solar to do the
indexing for more real-time
search
so that's the stack used at tumblr
so for the search online framework
essentially
so this is one really key piece for the
search online because it kind of
provides
it first of all it generalized the
search flow the common flow into
about six stage the query passing stage
the retrieving stage
and signal fetching
then
ranking then fetch the documents to end
the filtering pretty much all the
services follow this kind of
pattern
so we have a one
kind of implementation we call search
base implements
all the common boilerplate code for
example how do you do
execute the whole flow how do you
pass result from one stage to the next
stage how to do caching
we have multi-level caching
application can configure how do you
want caching and how do you log other
different pieces of data the profiling
of the performance uh also you can
choose to
execute our search either in a
synchronous mode or asynchronous mode
then we also have this editorial
capability so that you can
based on your need you can kind of
block some of the results or inject some
results so all these are common to the
search services we built on top of this
framework
each service the only thing they need to
worry about is
really how to
pass the query and based on credit pass
the query how to retrieve a set of
documents from much larger space so you
certainly recall candidates
documents then what are the signals
you're going to fetch for each of
documents then you do ranking
so very specific to each service then
you wrote a kind of a class uh by the
way this online framework is right now
is written in the php uh
for many of the reasons because
we already have a lot of plumbing
work at php we have bicycle
perfect timing
plumbing
so um
we choose to do it in php even though it
has certain limitation of the php it
doesn't have really true concurrency but
for for right now we are happy with that
um
we we might want to move this out from
the our php layer uh at some time
and for the offline we we also viewed uh
uh column of
batch processing kind of framework
so we generalize a lot of building
blocks so we can construct
the jobs to process data very easily
as you can see we have four type
different jobs
and the underlying we have for example
some very generic term generators so we
can do quickly inverted index generate
the term and also there was a top k
indexer
and we also have a process called
lucille ii
which is have a many classes can be
reused which is written in scouting
um
for the
once
all we've written all these jobs they
can compose as a workflow with this
workflow engine we build in-house
so this working workflow engine will
first resolve all the dependency
because each job they can
depends on the upstream job the results
it can it's all expressed in a
configuration file this engine will take
this configuration and
construct the workflow and execute
it also providing some common uh
functionality like it can do the
versioning uh whenever it ha generate
new version of output you can do
uh the difference generated we call it
delta so when we propagate this output
to the data layer only the difference
the delta product needs to be uh
propagated usually it's only have
while two percent
of change we really need to propagate
and because the data is very big and
it's all very important that we have
this integrity check because
we don't want
our users see uh kind of incomplete
results so we we spent a lot of time to
make sure we have a good verification uh
integra checking the data and uh have a
lot of like failure detection and alerts
it's all built into this frame this
workflow engine so each individual job
don't need to worry about this so this
saves a lot of development time
and also make sure the quality of data
is good
so
that was more about in the in general
the frameworks architectures in next
couple of slides i want to go to a
little more details about implementation
so first thing is about indexing
indexing is very important for search
so and the first question we want to
answer at tumblr in this very specific
particular environment is we have a lot
of data
as i mentioned we have huge amount of
posts
uh we have 70
72 billion posts so how to index uh if
we index all of them
uh does that really make sense so with a
lot of like uh
kind of debating we
we do a math and we we realize uh first
of all we don't need to
implement all the posts especially the
root blocks which is a big portion of
all those posts because we divide the
posts into original posts and reblogs so
first kind is that we only index
original post but even with original
posts if we look at back to all the way
to 207 it's a lot of them and
the best we can do is we need 600
machines back then 600 machine for
tumblr as startup was a huge number of
machines
i mean back then i mean before followed
by yahoo right
so we did a
quite some
design and we end up with a solution is
that we
uh
build a three tier in the in index the
first tier is we call it recent
so
we take last six weeks
of original posts we index all of them
then we also look back four years
then we we have a certain criteria
we use popularity as main criteria to
select we call the popular posts
then we also have this old
tag index which is not that great but it
still can serve when for example solar
failed it can do it as backup so we have
this three-tier
indexing uh scheme so we were able to
manage down to 40 machines which is a
big uh
like uh cost saving and uh
we did some testing in terms of coverage
we take some random queries and
go back to the hive then we see if we
have all the post index what's the
difference and difference is really
small uh because really for most queries
we have lots of content even in last six
weeks
and if really some rare queries
uh then we go back this four years with
this popular post if still you cannot
serve which means either the posts you
are looking for are not that great or we
just don't have that so
um and also with this folding machine
setup we are able to serve up to 4 000
credit per second which is non-cash
which means go
directly to the uh solar cluster
another thing we do is because we're
trying to really minimize the machines
we won't use
is that we
make our index very lean
we separate all the
volatile signals from the index which
means for example the popularity which
is keep changing for post we don't
start with the
index within the index
which eliminate a lot of reindexing
efforts uh it also gives us a more
independent way of how to implement more
signals how to store them how to serve
them
another
link index is we don't store any text
information other than the index itself
so
the main advantage is that it's dropping
the memory footprint of the index
because we our goal is trying to fit as
much of uh
as index into the memory as part because
that's dramatically increased the
performance and the reduced latency
so
the so that's the things we we do for
indexing
and for ranking right now is still very
quickly evolving we
we have some decent ranking but it's far
from perfect and uh
right now in the production we use a
rather small set of signals
um like global popularity which includes
the
cons of for example likes how many how
many people like your post and how many
people blog your posts and how many
people follow a blog it's kind of global
popularity we also have this concept
called local popularity for example in
the block search
we'll look at
query term
not only
how many total likes of this blog
received but we also looked
only the posts contained this term and
then we
we're trying to aggregate the likes on
those subsets of posts it's kind of we
project based on the
query content user and query and also in
a personalized recommendation we also
look at the user itself
uh
we not only look at the overall follow
cons of the blog but we also look uh how
many follow actually come from your
friends so with this kind of locality uh
respect to
exactly which user and which query it
actually improved the relevancy quite a
bit
uh another important signal
we for the recommendation we have this
week a b testing framework uh so
basically it allows to put a small
percentage of traffic for a given
version of recommendation uh
so for example
one percent traffic then the main metric
we see is called follow rate um so for a
new version if it's follow rate is
better than the previous version that we
consider it's a gain uh but we also
break down
our user into different buckets because
sometimes
uh some some version some algorithm may
work in a particular bucket better than
uh other buckets the bucket that we
usually developed by uh our user how
many people they follow right now
because this essentially see for new
users they usually follow less people
and for
more senior users they probably follow a
lot of so they have different behavior
so uh so that's how we measure uh
our
versions of the implementation
therefore textual relevancy is also very
important for especially for post search
so we
we look at
how your query matched within the post
is it the exact match uh what's the
proximity of the different words
and also we we differentiate do you
match against tag or some other text
because
tag of a post usually carries
better relevancy
because people spend time trying to
summarize attack their post with
a good
words that that usually carries more
weight
uh then reasons is also important for
for example post search
uh so that's the kind of ranking and
uh it's a big direction for us to
continue to do come up with better
signals and do better ranking
for the duplicate illumination at tumblr
we have a lot of duplicate duplicate
content some of them uh because there
was third-party tools allow users to do
revlogging but
we don't know easily blogging and some
of that is user they copy the content
and
you just pretend these are original
posts to gain their popularity so
uh sometimes it's very embarrassing when
you do search you see lots of likes
almost identical content so we spend
some efforts to eliminate all those
duplicates we do two kind of duplicate
illumination wise in the index time
we're using the
post signature mainly look at the
tags of a post and also we require tags
has to be more than
a threshold number so that we
don't really kill too much um
kind of like uh coincidentally they have
same tag
uh this n is actually a pretty big
number in the search time we also look
at the media the media hash because a
lot of posts at tumblr they carry
media information either photo or video
audio so we have
for all of them we have a hash
so
for those hash
if we have certain way to match them
against each other and so that's we also
take advantage of that to do the media
level the
another thing we do is called a new dee
because sometimes some posts are same
but people might end up with adding
one or two tags or remove a few tags so
so we also
have a way to detect this with certain
precision uh
the the thing is that we have so many
great content which give us a bit uh
space that even we make some mistakes we
still probably have some great content
to show up well because we're not
detecting those
might lead worst user experience so so
we tend to be a little bit more
aggressive right now uh to do the de
um
also search platform so
this is about like solar electro solar
cloud which probably there's a lot of
debates like which one is better uh
what i'm trying to do is just see
what we tried uh so at tumblr we first
actually we started with elec search uh
artist was actually helping us give us
some help on uh solving some of the
problems but um for quite some time uh
we
there were some main issues that uh
lectured back then the class of like how
do you form a class that was there um
it's very like a black box you you have
very little information about this and
when it works is great
but when
uh sometimes when you restart the
cluster it it just doesn't form and
it enter into a called a yellow state
it's not red but it's not green it
doesn't work uh and our engineers
usually will spend a lot of time and
trying digging and it's just really hard
to even understand why what causing this
uh so
even with
i mean all the expertise from others we
we didn't we are not able to get the
bottom of it so we switched to the solar
cloud
because solar collar also offer very
good functionality in terms of the
clustering distributed search
uh it works pretty well until we put a
lot of
load we're trying to simulate our
traffic load by
setting up at the same time doing a lot
of indexing a lot of search then we're
starting to see problems
one of the major problems we observe and
we don't have a good solution is that
because we do a lot of replica to
offload the search traffic and
what we found is that one replica
can slow down
the whole indexing of the same shard
so
i dig into a bit of code of solar cloud
it seems the leader has
keep a certain buffer so if uh one
replica doesn't acknowledge after
certain maximum size it will wait trying
to wait
uh and stop sending to the rest of
replica so essentially because every
second that we have thousands of posts
we need to index so easily we're causing
a backlog so that the freshness of
search results are largely
kind of delayed so again we trying to
solve this problem but with no avail so
and we have deadline to meet so we end
up with actually go back to the plane
solar and we wrote our own customized uh
clustering management and as right now
it works just just fine and we don't
really see any problem uh so of course
um
at some point we still probably still
want to go back to review
and test the solar cloud when uh all the
like glitch has been errored out but as
for right now we stay with uh this uh
basic solar solar 4 with some of our uh
our customized code
yeah so our take is that
and functionality wise i really like the
design of the search and the solar cloud
all the easy needs to use
but
solar
plane solar just seems still be a lot
reliable in the
production environment like us we have
at the same time a lot of indexing and a
lot of search
um
last thing i want to mention a little
bit is uh
one lesson we learned
at tumblr is we have lots of data a lot
of traffic seems
best way to really to meet both ends is
if
the search is not time sensitive
we should do a lot of pre-computation
because this really gives you
the resource to do more sophisticated
either processing or analysis
and you don't don't have this pressure
you have to okay
you only have 500 milliseconds go we
don't have this pressure in offline time
uh so
um
of course the limitation is that if the
application itself is time like the post
search you have to follow especially in
recent mode you have to give use up to
uh like
a second for example when user hits post
they expect their post have to show up
like within a second
so for that it's not applied but for
many other
search applications like tab has it
doesn't change much
the research is stable and the
recommendation block recommendation
again it's not gonna change over a
second you want to like recommend a
different blog so for all those uh less
time sensitive data we do a lot of
pre-computation use our powerful hadoop
cluster
uh so that's one important lesson we
also learned uh when we're building the
tumblr search
um what's next for tumblr search uh one
big thing we want to do is uh we call it
in blog search
so
right now
if you go to any tumblr blog
uh the only thing you can search again
is similar like the
post search you can only type one single
tag and internally it's again it's a
master table uh indexed with tag id so
we think that blog
what we want to do is that we want to
provide functionalities given any blog
you can search not only original posts
but also loot blogs and likes and the
difference between in-blog search
to
like regular searches that it only
searches within one blog so which makes
a lot of things easier because when you
index you can uh separate the data from
um different blogs so you only index one
blog grade like in the in the loose
scene essentially they use different
they color fields so uh and innovating
generator binary data format is that
different fields they have totally
dependency so in the retrieving time it
could be really fast
and another big thing for us to do is to
improve the ranking
so we already started seeing some gaming
some spamming we're trying to
gain the popularity of search results so
we want to
devise a set of more spam resilient and
more effective signals
and
once we have more signals handcrafted
scoring function is not going to be that
great so we're also trying to apply
machine learning to use signals plus all
the
user feedbacks to
to to rank better of results
in the recommendation side right now we
mainly rely on more in the kind of
collaborative filtering side to generate
the recommendation
um
one thing we want to do is we we
actually wanted to go more directly to
see given user given the and the content
can we um model the topic directly so
that we can using the topic to uh match
between users and the content uh by
understanding what are the interests
uh it could be supervised it could be
unsupervised
but essentially we we're trying to do
recommendation based on interest
and that would be another good
supplementation to what we're doing
right now
last thing is about content discovery
always we have more content than user
can consume so how to detect really
interesting content and that user
uh know and so they can uh more
appreciate like tumblr as a big uh
content network uh what's what's the
economy might be interested so that's a
very
big and ongoing effort we want to do the
better efforts on the content discovery
so
that's pretty much i think the talk so
if you have any questions
uh i would like to
to answer
and before that as you see we are hiring
so if you are interested about seeing
all this awesome content and work on the
search
please
talk to me or some of my teammates
yes
uh for the ski so the question is about
the schema
how do we index for example so right now
the main data we had the post and and
the blog so between them we have
different schema but for the post
the schema is really simple because
we have
tag is one very important the fields we
also have title we have
body tags we have
caption all those things
for right now we actually only
differentiate
the tag and the rest of the
text so
and
for them we do
some basic
text uh analysis like stopwatch removal
and stemming like using the porta2
algorithm to do stemming
uh
then pretty much then we we give just
put on a solo then index created
inverted index
so so that's how we index them yeah
we don't really have very complex schema
artists you want to
yeah i will
uh let me repeat the question so uh
because i think paul is recording this
so the question is about uh when we move
from one platform to another platform
what are the versions do we try
different versions of this one platform
right is it
correct yeah the question was were you
using it and then it uh outgrew it
or were you
testing it as a prototype
oh um we actually
stick with index surgery for quite some
time uh
some of the features with electrode
actually uh was in production
when life our user actually was using
that
that's why we have a lot of pressure to
keep the life and running and uh
and that's why we actually bring uh all
this uh and his team trying to
really make this thing work because we
really like like search as functionality
but
uh unfortunately um with a lot of
efforts with that
the version available back then uh it
doesn't really if our particular
application doesn't work
uh
it basically the
failure like almost every probably every
other week it will have one major
uh
failure which will cause the downtime of
that service for a few hours
uh so
i mean that's just very serious and we
it seems there was no easy solution just
to get rid of that with confidence that
okay we we know what's a root cause and
here's a solution and we cannot so
uh
yeah i mean for us we want to have the
predict uh we can predict like this
service is available and if even
something goes wrong as long as we know
the root cause i mean we are comfortable
but this like search is had too many
magic happen inside so
we we decided to go with solar cloud
which definitely provides more
transparency that we can we can see
what's going on yeah
hi
can you repeat that again
um so the question is about how much the
cost uh playing to the decision to
choose solar against
uh other choice so pretty much the cost
was uh we didn't see any like increase
for example number of machines
performance-wise they're comparable i
think uh so the cost was not a major
factor for the decision yeah
reliability is really the the things
eventually leads us to the solar yeah
please
uh so that's a good question so um
insert team we pretty much uh uh
we
we think we are language agnostic as we
for example in offline we have support
like different language uh
the the key thing is we try to build a
good framework so that it can
support
in the very high level support the
job which is written in different the
language or in the software for example
we
in the online we have this using script
as a bridge to
from the php they can talk to different
services for example written in a java
or scala
but i think this also cost is that we do
see those redundancy things has been
written so
i think
it's a it's a kind of trade-off
in the beginning because people come
different background we need to get
things done so
i think we are willing to that
happen but once we have a team and we're
building a lot of
things within a company it's probably
actually a good idea to consolidate
things into one two
uh language because then you can reuse a
lot of things
so i think we are
especially for the offline we one thing
we want to try is we more want towards
the scouting because it has a lot of
great properties and
especially in terms of the use of the
usability and also the modular things
seems pretty good for like a bigger team
to work together with so yeah
at least
um
yeah uh this definitely is a very good
question uh the thing is for search the
main thing we we measure
uh right now is we we measure some
engagements about actually this happens
only when we view the new search
so
uh but when we
look at because tumblr is a great uh
social network so a lot of things we
learn from our users is that we have
certain queries we can we can see our
people are very uh
like speak out they whatever they don't
like they will put it up on tumblr so
uh for us a lot of times when we release
a new feature we just go to tumblr and
see how users respond to features and of
course we are prepared user tends to be
whoever wrote the post uh a little more
uh
probably um
towards a little more negative to the
new features but we we do see a lot of
appreciation especially when us after we
took the ui initially because we also
introduced new ui in the this grid
format which which is great i personally
like that more than the list because it
allows you to
look more and in the search results but
a lot of people they like the list
format
so well
so they actually kind of like have a lot
of
negative comments but as soon as we give
them a choice they can either using grid
are using the list most people are very
very positive about new search
functionality and now they can search
not only just single tag multi-tag they
also search like full tags so i think
from that is it's a big win at the same
time the search volume
uh is increased but that's less often
because really once you have a better
search sometimes you might see
not necessarily your search volume would
jump because they might actually in the
first search in the first page you'd
already find what they want so uh that's
kind of like double side but a better
better measurement would be engagements
which right now we're starting to report
daily uh but unfortunately we don't have
that number before so uh
uh moving forward what we want to do is
for the search we also want to do like
recommendation we want to build this a b
testing framework so that we can see
between different release
how are we moving this kind of metrics
like uh do people like more often in
search results they follow other
people's blog more often things like
that yeah
okay i'll probably go this side for
questions yes please
uh yes
um
to be honest this thing was uh so the
question is about
the serialization this protocol where we
choose shift uh against other available
ones uh the quick answer is this
decision has been made even before i
joined tumblr so
yeah i think it works
whatever it works is good
yeah
uh peace
uh i didn't get a second part of your
question
oh right so uh the question is about how
do we decide what to index what not
index
uh as i mentioned earlier
right now the criteria is
mainly based on popularity we don't look
at a type of content
we don't trying to kind of like please
the content and see okay this is bad
kind of we're trying to index uh the
content then leave the choice the user
we do have uh option for users to say
call save search you can see better
content and uh like more safe kind of
not as a better but safer content
but also if you want to see all kind of
you can see that
for the choice mainly for the
engineering and
this consideration so
we use popularity which means
if people like your post more
uh
like loot block more than just get a
chance we will index them and if we have
really unlimited resource
at a certain point we might just index
all of them
yeah
please
uh as of right now we only have one data
center uh so
but even with a multi-data center
i think it won't be a big issue because
we still can uh so essentially we can
have um
multiple
file guides for example oh sorry the
question i want to repeat question is
that uh is our this replication schema
is
we think one data center across the
center the question the answer is that
right now tumblr we only have one data
center so the solution was within one
data center but i think that can also
apply to multi-descended by easily by
lubricate uh in the file file guys level
so we can have basically different
consume consume identical stream and in
a different data center we can then we
can build the same index because as long
as the input is same then the index
should be should be same yeah
please um
to be honest i think mysql works pretty
well
in uh
but and i don't have really much
experience uh with the other
um
database uh you you will mention but uh
we have pretty
good uh database team at tumblr and they
have a lot of expertise on making
massive work in the scale i mean we have
a huge massive database because we have
such great
such massive content
and
so
and again this decision was made before
even uh long before i joined the tumbler
so we
at a certain point we might start to
review this mysql without always working
because at a certain point maybe it was
really get to a point we need to have a
better technology but as of right now it
works pretty well so
uh we didn't get to the point to
change that yet
i probably go decided for take one
question yeah um
great question uh so questions about a
photo analysis
our phone
phone name ah okay
i saw this photo analysis so uh
we actually uh
no right the answer is uh phone analysis
and we don't do that
oh we just didn't get to yet so as i
said there was a
a lot of things i'll probably add that
to one of our actually to-do list to to
consider that
thank you
photo analysis actually uh is one very
interesting area and
especially recently there's a lot of
acquisition in this domain so uh
yahoo which is right now we under this
big family yahoo they actually have
quite a few companies they bought
recently have specialized
technology in analyze the photo for
example
it checked the same thing like text but
also trying to
annotate the entity in the
photo
in yahoo lab they they have something
which is basically uh of course it's
still right now is research but
in the in the very good stages that for
most celebrities actually given the
photo
with pretty good precision you might be
able to uh identify them that actually
because a lot of photo posts at tumblr
they
may have don't have tag or very little
tag because people some people they tend
to publish good content without annotate
them right so if we can actually use
additional
photo analysis
to get more information so that can help
search a lot yeah
um
content if it
contains some other text it will become
less of an issue but for the
for example if the tag is only saying it
contains a photo then
there's a couple ways one way is analyze
thought itself secondly is maybe you'll
go back if there's a certain way we can
know okay where this photo comes from
and
for example some people do
put a source of where this photo comes
from then
one
option we are looking at is trying to go
back to crawl that page uh
to find the surrounding text
so that's another approach essentially
is getting more text
on that yeah
yes please
so the question is when we re-index
uh how do we
swap the new index so
for the post index we
uh
the only time when we index is the post
change changed right so that's
essentially is a building by solar so it
will handle uh
like take the new content because it
will actually delete all the ones
override all the ones
so
that's not
particularly we are worried about this
and the only time is that when
um
when we we have to recycle the whole
because we we said we keep raising the
six weeks
so when one week become like seventh
week
uh so we do have we're using solar's
this uh calm uh atomy uh kind of uh
command so we we kind of manual we have
uh in our index aside we have this
policy to see we once
uh a call become out of date we will
delete them dynamically so yeah
yes yes
then we uh replicate them across
different servers so right now actually
our core is every week we create a new
core so that's we consider that shard
yeah
so for the replication as i said we are
using plain solar again our indexer
managed this replication so the way
we're doing is we have we split the
queue once we uh read posts from file
geyser we then we multi multiplex them
to different
level
and each of them are added identical to
each other but they don't have any
communication between them so
let's get rid of the complexity
yes yes
and this is all controlled by indexer so
so that makes sense everything we can
control we we know exactly how the
location happened how the shouting
happened and if something goes wrong we
can find the root cause and fix it yeah
uh might go this side for one question
uh for the
client side for the tab hat we do
cache
if you ever type this thing it will it
will cache for the session
uh
but because our tab has really fast
uh anything beyond that we don't do uh
so so pretty much it only do very basic
caching
so yeah
uh yes may misuse the concept
for the indexing uh
i think it i didn't remember the number
i i would think uh it's um
actually in general it's not a very big
because we have so many content right
the percentage i think and mostly not
more than five percent
if i have to give a number i think it's
but it's still even even one percent of
the posts are going to be huge and also
really what they matter is in the search
time are they
appearing in the search results or not
you can have billions of content as long
as they don't
show up in the search we don't care but
that's why we do a lot of other search
time duplication because that's actually
really the key we don't want users see
duplicates when they do search yeah
yes please
uh so the question is about um how do we
uh
take like
consider shouting when we're ranking
data
so
essentially right now the scheme is we
because we we shut the data based on
recency
so when we're doing retrieving we
actually give and because reasons is
also important in ranking so right now
we usually we fetch
more recent data only when the recent
data is not enough then we
go to our it's called top
popular partition now we fetch
additional ones and once we have this
the ranking is pretty much similar we
combine recency textual relevancy and
popularity
not right now but categorization is one
thing in our roadmap
we're trying to
there's quite a few things like all the
search there's a first we want to do a
better job on analyze the query like
detect the entities and also what type
of entities because different type of
entities might have
we might need a different ranking
or retrieving strategy
uh right now there is no learning it's
all handcrafted but the the thing we're
looking at mostly we want to look at
things like decision tree to to learn
the ranking
ranking formula yes
yes
two more questions
yeah because i think we have to uh close
the office
so
um
yes
uh so the question is about uh how do we
um in a b testing what does really
backing means right
uh right so the the question is uh do we
doing the right thing when we do mb
testing when we do marketing uh i think
i probably misleading you a little bit
is that when we do uh a b testing first
thing is that we put a user into a
percentages that data selection is
actually uh pretty much randomized it's
we don't do any we just uh
trying to have a very even distribution
across our whole user base
but once we get results when we're doing
analysis not only we look at the overall
number in that
user we we're doing we give a new
version right but we also break down
the user who are seeing new version into
different buckets based on certain
criteria so that we can better
understanding how uh different backup
users respond to this yeah okay
all right so last question uh
adam
yeah last one so
all right i think
so
um
uh yes if you think each tag is own
category that's we have something but we
don't really differentiate that much
right now for the categorization we're
starting to work on the trending
detection so we're trying to categorize
different trends but that's pretty much
it we'll do more on that side so i just
want to let you know um we have a great
bar close to company hottings
and some of my teammates adam
it's uh over there and bennett they're
going to go go to buy and if you
any of you have interest to out
you can find them
i have to go home after kids so
sorry yeah thanks again for coming and
this hope you enjoy